Charles Davis how are you Charles I'm
doing great rich thanks for calling me
for the celebration I just mentioned
someone earlier today yes we you know I
think the the Eagles rookies reported
today okay among other teams at cetera
I'm the veterans can't get the vetted
right so so so the excitement level all
right well when do these teams report
remember when we were kids and we could
not wait to hear the words pitchers and
catchers report yes sir and that has
been superseded by when do these NFL
teams go to camp rookies and
quarterbacks report yep rookies and
quarterbacks report remember when we
were kids that used to be with it what
they call that the offseason training
quarterback school was with the
offseason training with the OTAs and
mini camps are now it's called
quarterback school so yeah never QB
forgot about that I forgot about that
mount now everybody now everybody's got
a TV segment called quarterback school
right I mean it's yes yes they do I just
thought about that and I heard you
teasing the pop culture segment and you
know I'm on pins and needles on that one
yeah the TV audience yeah I did TV
audience I just dropped that there's
some huge pop culture news that just
popped and Brockman says to hold it for
the news segment which is in the middle
of the show correct yeah but an hour
from now 60 minutes all right and I'm
gonna end up having to take a 60-second
break in the middle of this conversation
but I do want to start out with the
first thing to me the number one story
coming out of the draft it was something
that you were in the midst of on day
three of the draft where you and Daniel
Jeremiah were sitting in between me and
mike Mayock and thankfully there was a
wall of you and Daniel damn I think Mike
wanted to he was coming at me and I
think you recall what I'm talking about
right now it's it's Lamar Jackson and
he'll in the world they're going to get
him on the field every snap when he
wants to be called only a quarterback
and be only a quarterback and if he's
lines up in the slot you know and they
give him the ball that's obviously all
well and good
but if he lines up in the slot and he's
gonna be their future quarterback don't
you know that he's not gonna be running
a route my question for you is how do
you see things playing out so far they
were the first team to report in
Baltimore what read me some tea leaves
on this front Charles well the tea
leaves it operating or they're going to
work their best to number one have him
be a quarterback first versus first last
and always we know that but I think
they're gonna work with him as well on
being on the field and showing that
there is value in that
whether we're showing the Wildcat stuff
whether we're showing as you said him in
a slot and things that can be done out
of it and you notice they're not shy
about letting us media types know about
all this you notice that they've been
very open about trying to do a number of
different things with him because they
want to make sure everybody that they
play it's got to start dealing with the
dealing with stuff they won't get it out
there right here right now I think that
he's going to have packages that
depending on how the game flows that
they can try it out there and turn him
loose on them but I also talked to
someone today from Baltimore camp yes
who has said they've never seen Joe
Flacco like this ever what is what is
like this mean meaning he is embracing
this challenge he is bouncing around
staking his turf I'm not saying it in a
bad way because you know you all hear
about the the quarterback who shunned
the rookie yes and won't speak to now
I'm not about that it's about Joe Flacco
showing up in shape wanting to make sure
the team knows that he's filled a
quarterback and eager to embrace this
thing and get his team back into the
playoffs so to me Baltimore's kind of
got the best of all worlds right now and
a lot of it just be dictated on how the
season unfolds the best as we all know
we all know they be I get back to the
playoffs i watch we probably got a
sweeping mandate there no no you know
what I don't like I know how that what
the owner feels about his coach yeah and
the coach you know I mean would be on
the street for the proverbial Rob Ryan
five minutes John Harbaugh
pretty much so I don't I don't know I
mean but let me just take this other
piece first and then we'll take a quick
break and come back and there's a
breakdown news out of Cleveland
interestingly enough
um that I love it all these training
camps are up and running that that even
yes best of both worlds that Flacco is
engaged and he's in shape and he's in
charge and he's winging the ball all
over the place and Lamar Jackson is
dynamic and he is a game-changing talent
that at some point though you're not
gonna put this game-changing talent out
there over in the middle to get blown up
if he's now the future at the
quarterback position and also if you do
take Flacco off the field for a couple
of plays to have Lamar Jackson run the
offense and you're getting plus 30 plus
40 yards that in some of these plays I
mean at some point you can't just keep
splitting the baby here Charles right
now the rubber will meet the road
depending in it as I said before rich
this season will dictate things for them
because you're right look John Harbaugh
is in a different spot than most head
coaches would be because of the owner
remember the new GM was the assistant GM
for all those years under Ozzy so it's
not like it's a brand new I've got out
my own people type of a new GM so that
plays well for them but they haven't
been it's been four out of five years
I'm gonna playoffs the big deal where do
you go with this and especially in the
division where Pittsburgh is the clear
head and shoulders favorite above and
everyone else is just chasing right now
Baltimore is in a chase position and
that's very unusual for them cincinnati
may very well be as good as baltimore
this year which is a very strange thing
to say one of them has got to fight it
out to try and slug it out and see if
they could be the second team by
pittsburgh as we sit here right now I
don't know if you're aware of the news
that's going on in Cleveland but the
news is this the general manager John
Dorsey saying that they are talking
about bringing in Dez Bryant we all know
that Josh Gordon is out for potentially
the foreseeable future and if he comes
back then they will have I mean let's
just let's put it this way if Josh
Gordon is coming back and healthy and
ready to go with Jarvis Landry and David
yoku and Dez Bryant oh my gosh they're
gonna I mean that might be one of the
most physical offenses you could pinch
knit chub coming downhill to try and hit
you would cut with Carlos Hyde I mean
they're gonna keep hitting you in the
mouth to Cleveland Browns and can they
get Corey Coleman up to speeds from
flash - outside and remember they draft
Antonio Callaway out of Florida who was
a first round talent that Cleveland
drafted did a lot of people had taken
off of their board because of
off-the-field issues at the University
of Florida there's no denying his
athletic prowess at all so you're
talking about a Cleveland Brown Steve we
talked about it I think day three rich
at the draft about the Cleveland Browns
wide receiver room hmm and any team
that's you know won one game in the last
two years Josh Gordon appears to be
coming back I did raise an eyebrow like
will he be back
you know I mean yeah I'd be very leery
about putting all my eggs in that basket
in you know I'm hoping Josh does make it
back and makes it to camp and all them
tire said that back then and you're
gonna add a Dez Bryant and then I was
very against them drafting Antonio
Callaway ok I'm one of those people he
would not have been on my board but
athletically oh hi I get why I just
think I did just thought you know you
got Joshua already got Corey Coleman
already in Jarvis Landry I didn't know
that you needed to add that to your room
but he may very well end up being a
player for them so they've got a lot of
things that they're gonna have to work
through not to not the least I've
mentioned we know Tyrod Taylor is there
and four huge acts and that's wonderful
because he's gotta win games early but
John Dorsey is a brand new GM who went
out on the proverbial limb and took
Baker Mayfield number one overall it's
right I mean we had Mary Kay Cabot on
the other day and she said that based on
her reporting that the Browns want Tyrod
Taylor to win this job and take that win
job know that he's gonna get the job and
that essentially that Baker's not gonna
get the reps to try and be able to earn
it because they want to win now that
they've lost enough games they owe it to
the veterans in the room and I was
saying to myself how in the world is
something like that happened with all
due respect to Tyrod Taylor who I
nothing but the highest regard and this
would be an incredible opportunity for
him if he does get the starting job like
everybody says out of Cleveland he's
going to get and not even have to win it
but when you take a kid num1 overall
number one overall and he's got that
braggadocio sness that you need and has
the ability that we've seen and we've
seen what the Shawn Watson's done and
and Carson Wentz is done and just with a
little bit of sea legs under him Jared
Goff has done how do you not get Baker
Mayfield a shot here Charles I'm a big
proponent of if you're going to draft a
quarterback that high I'm gonna do
whatever I can to get him ready to play
early I'm gonna make him tell me he
can't make it early I've been like that
for years now we can go chapter and
chapter and verse on the number of guys
who have started as rookies and they
haven't all been bad experiences I mean
cuz Ritchie not the first day everybody
hits you with if you start a rookie
quarterback oh my god no habit or you
his first year doubt yeah I know Matt
Ryan went to the playoff his first year
he said did Andy Dalton so - Joe Flacco
right we can just go right on down the
line you could make this thing work if
you want to invest in it it's like your
jets
once it Donald gets signed the idea that
anyone other than Donald takes a snap
first game it's folly to me that's just
the way I look I grant you I would find
a way to get them on the field and go
ahead and play I get with Cleveland
saying well I'll take care of the bad
one - this one - I'm a big Tyrod Taylor
fan but you do move the trap Baker
Mayfield number one overall why wouldn't
you give him every time I don't
understand - is that you okay let's
let's take our lumps you know
Philadelphia 76ers processed style right
let's take our lumps and then when it's
time to hit the win it now button and
you that then then you you want to get
obviously a veteran out there and hit
the win it now button but you also don't
want to give like what ten into six and
ten eight and eight and then suddenly
okay we've got that going on now let's
try and break Baker Mayfield in like
don't at some point you've got it to
play this guy and you got to get the the
rust out of the way and you got to take
the rookie lumps out of the way or you
can get you can catch
like deshaun Watson and maybe win the
damn division Debra Jean Watson Lasher
didn't win the job right out of the gate
couldn't be not Tom Savage supposedly
until quarter number two right so I
believe you know I would go back and you
know I love the little brown if you like
so b.o.b what did you gain out of that
we get here
I guess the Apple that's an apple to the
orange of like obviously Tyrod Taylor
has more yeah you know going Forman
Savage I'm big not to really truly am
but at the same time you drafted that
kid number one overall and very few
people thought that was going to
actually happen do you think Josh Allen
starts enough do you think Josh Allen
starts in Buffalo
I actually don't I could be very
difficult for him to beat out AJ
McCarron I think McCarran is kind of
underrated in being that veteran guy
plus you've probably spent some time
with him haven't you rich I think
they're gonna have a very hard time
getting AJ McCarron out of the lineup I
really do because I think that he has
been working for this want jonesing for
this it want to be that guy now they put
themselves in a spot where you got to
figure it out with Josh Allen I think AJ
McCarron's gonna make it very very
difficult I don't know
I know these bridge quarterbacks are
there just in case these rookies aren't
ready to go and it gives you some
breathing room but you draft somebody
that's high they got a start at some
point you might as well yeah I don't
disagree way they've got to figure that
part out all I'm saying is they made
that move with McCarran who to me was a
better signing than let's say the Bears
of Mike Glennon the year before and then
and then the Bears made the move and
drafted moved up and drafted Mitchell
Travis key and I said he should have
started day one to me they just wasted
time on that one too
in this case I mccarran's a better
football player and so I think it's
going to be difficult unless they just
say you know something we're going
through rocky just you know whatever
we're just going with him let's go full
circle with you to wrap up this
conversation then we've some college
football in and ask the question that
the rest of my
Rich Eisen show compadres one ask into
this microphone okay which Harbaugh
needs to win more this year John or Jim
Charles I'm the surface I would say John
but I think that I think that Jim needs
it more for perception than anything
else I don't think he's in any trouble
at Michigan by any stretch of the
imagination I don't think that all I
think the administration is all in with
him all of that but I did notice a shift
which I thought was a very positive to
shift this offseason it was very quiet
in Ann Arbor and I thought that was good
for him just go just go coach the team
get him ready to go go play the gimmicks
and everything else that have worked and
giving him attention didn't he do those
anymore
people know he's there go get your
players and go do your thing and I think
it's also good for him
that they're actually picked lower than
what most people picked up in recent
years they think Michigan State ahead up
on Penn State ahead of my house day
ahead of all I think that's good for him
but I do think that he needs it for the
perception that this hire which has been
a phenomenal hire for Michigan in a lot
of ways gotta find a way to pay it off
with some big wins
Charles let's check let's chat again
real soon this is fun I look forward to
it you know you know anytime but tell
all the fellows hello for me
go ahead how you doing all right buddy
what's inside you got all right be good
okay you too brother that's Charles
Davis by the NFL Network and Fox Sports
who's gonna be in the booth again the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience